[Musique]
j'ai 38 ans je ne dirais pas en quoi
c'est un peu la seule chose qui me reste
je laisse les gens voient des paris j'ai
effectivement des problèmes parce que
dans ma tête très souvent je pèse le
poids déjà vu à 24 ans à 9 55 kg et je
me suis arrêté à ce poids là j'ai tout
essayé pour pour perte de poids que
j'avais
d'origine la relaxation des médicaments
des maisons diététique du yoga j'ai pas
mes deux filles c'est comme si je
m'étais fabriqué avant tout pour me
protéger
j'avais un frère elle était comme moi
ils ne disent pas trop de problèmes
[Musique]
françoise vous regarder souvent la
publicité mais ça m'arrive pouvait bien
obligé vous aimeriez vous semblez
certains même temps certains oui
certains oui mais certains pas du tout
par exemple les femmes voient leur salle
hier ouvre les pros tout y'a pas les ont
plus de ventre les ans plus de 500
décharné complètement je passe à
spécialement joli
les seules personnes de chez nous pas
jalouse que je trouve vraiment très
émouvante
les gamines de 15 ans sur les plages je
pense que là n'importe quelle femme de
toute façon ne peut pas rivaliser parce
que parce que c'est elles sont
magnifiques et que vous vous y allez
fort sur la plage le soir vous allez me
demande un maillot de bain mais non je
vais pas en maillot de bain sur la plage
je vais habiter sur la plage j'emmène
mon transat sur la plage je prends les
livres et je m'assieds dans vos transats
sur la plage sous un parasol
voilà ce que je fais à la plage on
voulait quand on est travailleur non je
ne vais pas m c'est un trop gros et ford
et pour moi est sûrement pour les eaux
je suis persuadé que les gens ne sont
pas tolérants
ou alors on peut admirer l'exploit ce
qui est encore pire quand j'entends des
gens dire regardez là pas de complexe
elle va sur la plage malgré je trouve ça
dramatique parce que c'est quand même
mettre les gens encore plus salée car à
mon avis trouvais ça injuste
je n'ai pas à juger je sais rien je sais
seulement que s'il regarde mes
contemporains
dans la société dans laquelle je suis et
que c'est pas très très vivable et c'est
tout et que ça fait un peu monstre de
foire et je suis pas d'accord
[Musique]
j'ai partout des problèmes de places
dans les avions dans les tgv dans les
cochettes au cinéma au théâtre sur les
chaises de café rien n'est fait pour moi
voilà c'est pareil mais je ne peux pas
rentrer
dans ma voiture c'est pareil je volant
qui vendent dans l'estomac les pédales
qui sont trop loin j'arrive pas à
envoyer
je ne trouve rien qui me conviennent
dans les magasins parce que soit c'est
des choses qui sont à ma taille mais
c'est des trucs de mémé collection de
mai mais triste sans aucune imagination
soit les magasins g2 le regard de la
vendeuse qui sourient et qui me plains
bien parce que je vais lui acheter
quelque chose qui en fait n'en pense pas
moins
comment se comportent les gens quand
j'allais au restaurant lesquelles les
gens qui sont en face de moi ou les gens
qui sont autour de moi les gens qui vous
voit manger au restaurant
j'ai un regard à mélanger entre la pitié
et un peu la méchanceté parce que qu'on
comprend pas quand même pour quelqu'un
comme moi mangeant plus donc
j'étais une jolie petite fille
j'ai même été mannequin pour enfants
mais ça l'étonné que je sois si même en
fait j'étais normal
ma mère l'était boulimie elle est
toujours et pour moi ma seule façon de
me rapprocher d'elle c'était d'accepter
ce qu'elle me donnait j'avais 24 ans
j'avais déjà des problèmes en plus je
mangeais plus je grossis serre et plus
jour aussi celle que je mangeais petit à
petit le regard des gens a changé
j'ai commencé à avoir peur de ce héros
car je n'étais plus enviable plus
désirable je me traitaient même du
bouddha et ça arrive encore à l'époque
j'avais rencontré un garçon ou se
plaisait un jour il m'a dit si tu avais
20 kg de moi je t'aurais ici
[Musique]
j'ai une petite fille de 4 ans et demi
qu elle s'appelle barbara
[Musique]
qu'est ce tu dis de mangrove en bambara
rien dit rien dit rien elle me trouve
belle et puis voilà quoi dit pas
grand-chose bon à l'école je sais que
c'est arrivé quand même 10 at elle m'a
dit que tu étais grosse tout ça quoi
mais on explique pourquoi père de
barbara ne vit pas avec moi il est il
vit ailleurs avec une autre femme née
marié il a un fils et nous vivons tout
les noirs et moi est-ce que je vous
avais déjà parlé avec avec lui deux
vient vous voir souvent non de temps en
temps une fois pourquoi seulement parce
qu'il peut pas faire autrement dans la
mesure où il a une vie légitimer et que
sa femme ne s'est peut-être pas notre
existence donc je pense que c'est dans
les occasions il peut effectivement s'en
aille chez lui de façon élaborée parce
qu'il ya des réunions sur paris les
choses comme ça qui n'habite pas paris
et est ce que vous êtes et ce que vous
avez essayé de cacher votre corps quand
vous êtes avec lui n'ont donc pas
vraiment l'acceptent aujourd'hui mais je
pense qu'il a acceptée même peut-être
mieux comment à la limite il y as embêté
pour moi de me voir comme ça et d'autre
part ça sécurise aussi parce que bon
y apporte de chance que j'avais pas voir
ailleurs donc ça c'est aussi une
sécurité pour lui comment ressentez-vous
le regard des autres hommes sur vous ça
dépend c2c des gens de couleur par
exemple c'est plutôt marrant parce que
c'est c'est des gens qui est
effectivement les femmes fortes ça
comptait fin d'un certain âge les autres
bah c'est un espèce de dédain mais vous
aimez séduire quand même pas pas dans le
padd encensement longtemps que je pense
qu'on peut pas séduire avec les formes
que j'ai je pense qu'on séduit à
d'autres niveaux
justement comment vous séduisez quand un
homme vous plaît par exemple je ne sais
pas comment je séduis je sais que des
fois ça se passe très bien mais façon
intellectuelle de trois façons j'ai
d'autres systèmes de séduction qui ne
sont pas sois belle et tais toi
cette chose je me pose pas vraiment
question vous avez eu d'autres aventures
à part le père de votre fille avait eu
deux aventures père de ma fille qui va
pas être content s'il voisins il s'est
vraiment bien sûr avant après je pense
qu'on appartient pas une petite personne
je sais les gens viennent avec moi c'est
qu'ils ont envie est ce que c'est par
curiosité de est ce que c'est je sais
pas je par curiosité de quoi je sais pas
je suis pas l'égal des hommes qui se
disent tiens je me verrais bien une noix
aux mystères et il aimerait bien grosse
pourquoi pas peut-être ces cinq d'autres
c'est autre chose c'est une espèce de et
pas de pouvoir séduction sexuelle comme
ça au premier abord donc
je pas vécu comme vraiment très
dangereuse et puis je pense que c'est un
peu ça
[Musique]
je pense qu'un homme ne voudraient pas
vivre en pleine lumière avec moi et puis
de toute façon j'ai toujours eu l'idée
que je ne pourrais pas
[Musique]